الله اكبر
ساعه انتظار طويله احساسها اشبه بايام
لكنها ختمت اسبوعها الاول بالفعل فالزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا دخل يومه
السابع وكفه الضحايا في ميزان العالقين
باتت الراجحه حاليا متخطيه عتبه الثلاثين
الف قتيل
سبعه ايام قادمه وتزداد سوادا مع توقعات
بارتفاع اعداد القتلى لنحو الضعف لكن كيف
بدات
زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه ضرب على بعد 17 كيلو
مترا قرب غازي عنتاب في الساعه الرابعه
وسبعه عشره دقيقه بالتوقيت المحلي تلاه
زلزال اخر واكثر من 650 هزه ارتداديه وفق
مسؤولين اتراك حل مدمرا في عشر ولايات
تركيه وخمس محافظات سوريه شملت حلب وادلب
عدد القتلى تخطى 7500 شخص في البلدين مع
استمرار معارك البحث عن ناجينه واعلن
الرئيس التركي حاله الطوارئ بالولايات
العشر المتضرره لثلاثه اشهر لافتا الى
التضرر حوالي 13 مليون وخمسمائه الف شخص
واحد عشر الف مبنى
ثالث ايام الكارثه شهد تحذيرا من اغلاق
النافذه الذهبيه للعثور على ناجين مع وصول
عدد القتلى الى اكثر من تسعه الافتيل
بعدها بيوم عداد الضحايا دقه عتبه العشرين
الفا مع استمرار عمليه البحث والانقاذ كما
سجل التاسع من فبراير وصول اول قافله
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر معبر باب
الهوى اجمالي عدد القتلى واصل ارتفاعه الى
اكثر من 22,000 بالاضافه 82 الف مصاب
حقائق وقاده اردوغان للاعتراف ببطء
استجابه السلطات التركيه للزلازل الجنوبيه
البلاد
مع دخول الكارثه يومها السادس اعلن مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري وقفه عمليات الانقاذ
لتبدا عمليات انتشال الضحايا العالقين تحت
الانقاض اما في تركيا فتواصلت عمليات
البحث مسجله معجزه قليله
[موسيقى]
اكثر من 23 مليون شخص تاثروا بالكارثه موت
واصابات وتشريد جروح توازي بعمقها شقوقا
في مبان شبه صامده وطرقات متقطعه
ينضم الينا من التاج جنوب تركيا موفد
العربيه عمار الهندي ومعنا من غازي عنتاب
ايضا مفرد العربي عبد المحسن الحربي اهلا
بكما ابدا معك عمار اي جديد عندك بمحاولات
الانقاذ
نعم طاهر نحن لازلنا ننتظر في الحقيقه ان
تخرج هذه الحاله التي لا تزال على قيد
الحياه بحسب المؤشرات وما يعني يتحدثون به
هنا رجال الانقاذ هم طبعا اخر شيء حدث
انهم طلبوا ماء واخذوا الحماله التي من
المفترض ان ينقلوا عليها الناجي تحت
الانقاض ولكن هذا منذ تقريبا نصف ساعه
وقبل خمس دقائق من الان طلبوا الصمت مره
اخرى وفحصوا مره اخرى ما اذا كان هنالك
اصوات وتاكدوا ان هنالك اصوات ويعني
الامور مطمنه ولكن كما قلت لك قبل ساعتين
ربما حينما كنا على الهواء ان مثل هذه
الامور يهيئ للبعض بانها سريعه يهيا للبعض
ان الامر خمس دقائق او عشر دقائق هو ليس
كذلك هو يعني يحتاج صبر كبير وهذا الصبر
الكبير لك ان تتخيل ان فرق الانقاذ التي
تتحلى بهذا الصبر الاصرار على العمل يعني
كم هي عظيمه يعني كم جهدهم عظيم جدا
بالفعل حينما يصرون على الوصول الى الناجي
تحت الانقاض رغم الصعوبات ورغم ما يعيق
عملهم ويوم ما يعيق وصولهم اليه
وانا الشيء الذي افكر به دائما طاهر ان
هذا قصر المسافه الفعليه نصف متر مثلا كم
يكلف من الوقت للوصول الى شخص ناجن ينتظر
ان ينتشر احد يده ويخرجه الى الحياه من
جديد نحن ننتظر كما تنتظر وكما ينتظر كل
من يقف هنا صعب معرفه طبيعه هذه العوائق
التي تواجهها الان تواجه فرق الانقاذ
صعوبات
اللوجستيه التي تواجههم في عمليه الانقاذ
بطبيعه الحال صحيح
صحيح صحيح على الاغلب تكون هنالك يعني
الحديد هو من اكثر الاشياء التي فيها
صعوبه خصوصا اذا كانت كمياته كبيره يحتاج
الى تقطيع والى قص والى ازاله وايضا
الاسمنت حينما يكون عباره عن كتل كبيره
يحتاج الى تفتيت بطريقه دقيقه جدا دون ان
يؤثر على حياه الشخص الذي يتواجد تحت
الانقاض ولكن مع التنويه طالب طاهر مع
التنويه بانه كلما طالت
نعم
كلما طالت المده كلما اصبح الخطر اكبر
ولكن ابرز ما نعرفه حتى الان انه على
الاقل لا تزال الحياه وانه طلبوا ماء
واخذوا الحماله منذ نحن صحيح صحيح وهذا
يعني سنظل نقول بانه يبشر صحيح الخير ان
شاء الله على الاقل بالنسبه الى هذه
الشخصيه او السيده اعود اليك بعد قليل من
الى غازي عنتاب الان مع مفرد العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي الكلمه لك الان عبد المحسن
ما الذي نعرفه عن غازي عنتاب تحديدا وما
يجري فيها باي جديد لديك
طاهر في الحقيقه انا لا استطيع الحديث
الان نظرا لانهم طلبوا لحظه صمت طيب
سنتركك اذا قليلا ونعود اليك لاحقا لحظات
الصمت هذه عاده يعني يطلبها رجال الانقاذ
والفرق المتخصصه من اجل يعني الاستماع
جيدا والانصات الى اصوات انين الى اصوات
يعني تصدر من تحت الانقاض في محاوله
لانقاذ من يمكن انقاذه رغم مرور هذه
الايام السبعه اذن يعني نحترم لحظه الصمت
هذه بطبيعه الحال عند
مفدنا الى غازي عنتاب عبد المحسن الحربي
ولكن نحن على تواصل مع المكانين ومع
الصورتين اذا احداها من غازي عنتاب على
يمين الشاشه وعلى يسارها من هاتاي مع عمار
الهندي والمحاولات لا تزال مستمره اذا
بالصوره على الاقل من غازي عنتاب وعلى امل
ان نعود الى عبد المحسن الحربي بعد قليل
يخبرنا باي جديد لانه حتى النائب الرئيس
التركي كان قال الليله بانه لم يفقدوا
الامل بانقاذ ناجين من تحت الانقاض رغم
الاعداد المهوله التي وصلت اليها اعداد
القتلى ان نتحدث عن نحو 35 في كل من تركيا
وسوريا هذا الموضوع سيستمر وسيستلزم يعني
اياما واشهرا وربما سنوات لكي تعود الامور
الى طبيعتها لكي تتوازن كل الامور مع
مختلف الاصعده ان كان في تركيا او في
سوريا لانه تبعات الزلزال كما هو كارثي
تبعته كارثيه ايضا وعلى مختلف الاصعده اذا
فرق الانقاذ في كل منها
تحاول الوصول لناجين تحت الانقاض بعد سماع
اصوات اذا يعني
نترك عبد المحسن قليلا لكي تنتهي حاله
الصمت ثم ربما يشير الينا بانتهاء حاله
الصمت بتمكن كلام كي نعود اليه بعد قليل
ولكن نشاهد الصوره تبقى امامنا اما فيها
الطائفه نشاهد رجال الانقاذ بكشافاتهم
الضوئيه على رؤوسهم بخوذهم بسطراتهم ايضا
يواصلون المحاولات ياخذون معدات بين فينه
واخرى الى هنا وهناك لكي يحاولوا استكمال
انقاذ هذه المراه تحت الانقاض على امل ان
يصلوا اليها قريبا نعود الى عمار
وعبد المحسن بعد قليل اذا بعد ان نشير الى
مشاهد الدمار على مدار اسبوع كامل من
كارثه الزلزال هذه المشاهد القاسيه قرى
سوريه سويت بالارض ومدن تركيا منكوبه
تحتاج لمليارات الدولارات للقيام مجددا من
خلال محاكاه افتراضيه سنعود بالزمن للوراء
الى اللحظه التي نادرا ما ترصدها الكاميرا
مع الزميله حنين الشؤولي
انقضاء الساعات الثقيله يصبح ما بعدها
اثقل ويصبحوا هذا المشهد حلما وماضيا في
اذهان ووجداني من عاصر الدقيقه الفارقه او
اقصر هكذا كانت المدينه قبل الكارثه
واللحظه القادمه نادرا ما توثقها عدسه
اللح
ظه لم تنشا فيها بؤره الزلزال تحت هذه
الارض لا التي اقف عليها بل في المركز على
بعد عشرات الكيلومترات وعمق 300 كم واكثر
هنا لدرجه الزلزال الدور الاكبر هذه هزه
اولى بقوه 6 درجات او هزه ارتداديه بقوه
خمس درجات
لاحقت زلزالا يفوقها قوه في درجه على
الاقل علميا الهزه اقل وطئه لكن هذا البيت
لم يصبر تداعى وانهار بحكم قدمه او سوء
معايير بناءه كارثه قد تحل بعشرات السكان
وربما بعض الماره ليسوا ارقاما بل الارواح
كانت امنه قبل ان تفاجاها الطبيعه
لكن امامك كارثه اكبر بالمقاييس والعواقب
ينظر الى دمار منزل او اثنين على انه
اضرار ضئيله وما سنوشك على محاكاته الان
نكبه عاشتها هايتي في 2010 كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه عام 89 تشيلي عامي 60 و 2010
وبقاع اخرى وقف سكانها المحظوظون منهم
امام خراب وترك الالاف ضحايا تحت الالقاب
هذا ما حل بجنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا بعد
هذه اللحظه كل دقيقه بحساب وكل ثانيه
بنفسه هناك كانت غرفه النوم وهناك غرفه
المعيشه او المطبخ او الباب
كل ما كان اصبح ركاما يتسابق الوقت لرفعه
مع الموت والحياه الانقاذ والانقاذ
الامل والالم
مجددا الى هطايا ومفرد العربي اعمار
الهندي عمار الكلمه لك الان اذا لم يكن
هناك لحظه صمت تستطيع ان تتكلم
لا لا بالعكس الجميع يعمل هنا يعني كل
الاجهزه والمعدات تعمل بكل طاقتها وحتى
العمال ورجال الانقاذ يعملون باقصى طاقتهم
في سبيل ان يخرج هذا الناجي من تحت
الانقاض لانه كما تعلم يعني هم ستكون
معجزه فعلا اذا اذا خرج وان شاء الله ان
يحدث ذلك ان شاء الله سالت مره اخرى قالوا
لي نعم هنالك صوت وهو حي ولكن انا ما لا
افهمه حقيقه يعني في بدايه الامر كان خيل
الينا وحينما سالنا قالوا لنا ان الامر
سهل يعني هي فقط بعض
يعني الامور تعيقهم بسيطه جدا ويسهل
ازالتها واخراج هذا الناجي ولكن استغرق
وقت وربما يستغرق وقت اكثر ولكنهم يعملون
باصرار وكل نصف ساعه تقريبا يطلب من
الجميع ان يصمت يعيد الكره لفحص ما اذا
كانت الاصوات لا تزال موجوده واذا كان
الامر لا يزال
على ما هو عليه وبالفعل يعني يثبت انه
الشخص تحت الانقاض لا يزال حيا وهنالك
طبعا كما قلت لك طائره من دون طيار فوق
هذا المبنى تصور وتجوب المنطقه يعني فوق
هذا المبنى تحديدا فوق العملات التي تحدث
هنا الان
الطاهر هذه هذا المشهد او عدم او عدم قدره
فرق الانقاذ على على الوصول للشخص الذي
يعتقد ان هناجن في الوقت السليم تكررت
حدثت يعني حدثت ان يكون فريق الانقاذ يعمل
لساعات وبالتالي حينما يتاخر او يكون تكون
المعوقات اكبر من اكبر من جهدهم واكبر مما
يستطيعون تقديمه يتاخروا ولكن ليس بذنبهم
يعني ليس ذنب عليهم ولكن هذا هو الحال
والواقع وبالتالي يصل متاخرين او يعني
يحول دون وصولهم دون
اللحظه المناسبه على اي طبعا يعني وجود
اذا ما حاولنا ان يعني نتوقع ونقرا المشهد
اكثر من حولك ربما نسالك اذا يعني ترى
يعني بعض الاهالي بعض الناس ممن ينتظرون
بعضا من اقاربهم من عائلاتهم من اصدقائهم
حول هذا المبنى تحديدا يعني العائله تركيا
العائله تركيه والشخص الذي يخص هذه
العائله موجود موجود والامن طلب منه ان
يقترب الى هناك وكان بالقرب من الموقع
وقام هو بنفسه بنداء عليهم ولكن هو يعني
شبه منهار طاهر لانه يعني كما تعلم كان
فاقدا للامل بشكل كامل وحينما اخبروه وعرف
في الامر وحدد مكان الشقه
والعمليات التي تحدث عاد اليه الامل من
جديد والان يتاخر الوقت هي هكذا طاهر يعني
لا شيء غريب يعني في المره الاولى التي
شهدت فيها موقف مشابه لهذا الامر انا
شخصيا احبطت ولكن بعد ذلك فهمت ان الامر
معقد اكثر مما نتخيل يعني ليس سهلا ان
تخرج شخص خصوصا اذا كان مكان تواجده صعب
يعني احيانا تكون العمليه سهله يعني اليوم
في هذه المنطقه تحديدا انا شهدت بام عيني
اخراج شاب اسمه عبد الله وقلتها مرارا خرج
بكل يسر وبكل سهوله يعني واجابهم سالوه
سؤال
واجاب اسمي عبد الله وبعد ذلك يعني ازالوا
بعض الركام وكتله اسمنتيه بسيطه وخرج
بسلام ونقل الى المستشفى ولكن في مثل هذه
الحاله وحالات مشابهه اخرى يكون مثلا
المبنى فيه طبقات ويعني الدلائل تشير الى
انه على قيد الحياه والفحص يشير الى انه
على قيد الحياه لا يمكن يعني يقع فريق
الانقاذ بين نارين النار الاولى انه متاكد
بان الشخص على قيد الحياه ولا يستطيع ان
يتخلى والنار الاخرى بان المسافه قصيره
ولكنها من حيث العبور طويله جدا هذا ما
يحدث على الارض في الواقع طاهر يعني حتى
يفهم المشاهد ما الذي يحدث هنا ولماذا في
احيان كثيره يعني بالامس نحن نتابع حاله
سيده
استمرت لساعات لانقاذها انا تلقيت رسائل
من اشخاص ما الذي حدث قلت لهم للاسف لم
تنجوا لان اتصلت باحد الرجال رجال الانقاذ
في اليوم اليوم صباحا واكد لي انها لم
تنجو يعني للاسف الشديد ورغم انهم كانوا
متاكدين جدا ولديهم اشارات واضحه وردود
افعال ومدركه وتعطيهم اشارات ولكن الساعات
هذه التي يعني يستغرقها فريق الانقاذ بسبب
ما ما يعيقه من امور صعبه
الى الشخص في الوقت المناسب ودون عودته
الى الحياه للاسف للاسف هذا صحيح ساعود
اليك بعد قليل عمار تبقي لنا الصوره لنبقي
عينا عليها مع المشاهدين واتحول العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي
جاهز معنا
فقدنا الاتصال بعبد المحسن الحربي
ولكن لازلنا نشاهد الصوره من غازي عنتاب
على الاقل كان في لحظه صمت قبل قليل طلب
منه ان لا يتحدث
وبالتالي من اجل سماع اصوات بدقه اوضح تحت
الانقاض وهذا ما يتكرر باستمرار في في كل
ايام محاولات الانقاذ بانتظار ان يعلن
يعني شيء ما ان نسمع خبرا سارا ان شاء
الله من يعني المكانين من غازي عنتاب ومن
هاتاي نتابع في هذه التغطيه عاد الينا عبد
المحسن عبد المحسن تسمعني اراك الان
نعم اسمعك طاهر بالفعل في هذا المكان قبل
قليل كنت لا استطيع التحدث بسبب لحظه
الصمت التي فرضت من قبل الفرق الاقيه
العامله في هذا الموقع حيث ان هنالك بصيص
عمل ولو انه قليل جدا ولكن يتم التعامل مع
اي صوت بهذه الطريقه يتم اسكات جميع
الحاضرين في هذه المنطقه لكي يتم ادخال
اما المستشعرات ادخال الاجهزه ادخال حتى
الكلاب البوليسيه لاستشعار ما اذا كان هذا
الشخص حي او محاوله ايجاد اي الطريق
للوصول اليه
عمليات ايضا
المحاوله على الحصول على طريق كان قبل
قليل في هذا الموقع تحديدا عصرا تم اكتشاف
موقع وهو كراج الموقف للسيارات تستطيع من
خلال الفرق السعوديه العامله في هذا
الموقع بان تدخل من الجهه اليسرى الى اقصى
اليمين وهو المكان الذي سمع فيه صوت
ايضا
في من خلال هذه
الساعات الماضيه يتم العمل من الجهه
اليمنى الى الجهه اليسرى يتم التمشيط يتم
ايضا وضع هذه الاليات والدخولها مباشره
الى اماكن ليست بالبعيده لانه هنالك اصوات
فيتم التعامل بكل دقه مع هذا
الموقع
عصرا ايضا الصوت الذي خرج من تحت الانقاب
كان اقرب ما يكون الى صوت طفل بحسب
المنقذين والمتواجدين شهود الاعيان الذين
سمعوا هذا الصوت وتحديدا كانوا متواجدين
في الداخل بالقرب من
الفرق الانقاذيه فبالتالي تم التعامل مع
هذا الصوت
ومحاوله فرض لحظات صمت بين الفتره والاخرى
كان قبل قليل قبل اكثر من ساعه قبل ظهورنا
في هذا المباشر الساعه الماضيه فرضت لحظه
استمرت الى ما يقارب 20 دقيقه ما ايضا
بعدها بخمس دقائق او باقل من خمس دقائق
فرضت صمت لحظه صمت ايضا جديده في محاوله
لتاكيد سماع هذا الصوت ووضع ايضا ايه حلول
ايه طرق اخرى يتم استخدامها مع هذا الموقع
المعقد الذي يتم العمل عليه منذ سبعه ايام
ايضا بالاضافه الى ذلك اليوم تم انتشال
عدد من الجثث في هذا الموقع ادت سيارات
السيارات المخصصه للجثث وانتشرت هذا
الموقع ومباشره بعد سماع صوت الطفل كان
هنالك بصيص امل فبالتالي شاهدنا مباشره
وصول سياره الاسعاف في هذا الموقع بالقرب
منه في محطه البنزين التي تقع بالقرب من
هذا
الموقع وهي بالمصادفه تقع بجانب
الحاجيات والاغراض والكتب والتذكاريات
لهذه الاسر وحتى الملابس
ان كنت تشاهدها في الصوره او نستطيع ان
نعمل عليها
تقريب من خلال الكاميرا يعني هذه السيارات
الاسعاف واقفه تماما بجانب هذه الاغراض
والمتعلقات الشخصيه والكتب وشاهدت ايضا من
خلال هذه الاغراض صور شخصيه
وتذكاريه لعدد من الاسر الذين سكنوا في
هذه البنايه المكونه من ثمانيه ادوار
وايضا من خلال هذه المحطه للبنزين رصدت
كاميرات المراقبه من خلال هذه في هذه
المحطه سقوط هذا المبنى
بثواني لا تتجاوز الثلاثه الثواني سقوط
سريع جدا بحسب شهود الاعيان وسكان هذه
المنطقه قالوا بان ثلاثه ثواني كانت كفيله
بان يكون هذا المبنى متساويا بالارض
النائب لم يستطع ان يستوعب ما الذي جرى
وربما هنالك اشخاص كثيرون من من
قضوا جراء هذه هذا الهبوط او هذا السقوط
قضوا وهم نائمون او ماتوا وهم نائمون في
هذه
البنايه بالاضافه
خلف الجرافه الان ذهبوا من وراء نقدر نعمل
نعم في الجهه الاخرى خالد شاهدت او طاهر
شاهدت
سيارات الاسعاف مباشره انزلوا سرير الى
الجهه الخلفيه
[موسيقى]
لمحطه
لا اعلم ان كان يتم التعامل مع حاله اخرى
في بنايه اخرى ام هي نفس البنايه ويتم
الاستعداد لشيء ما اما حمل مصاب او ايضا
هنالك مشهد اخر
كما تشاهد بعض الاهالي بدا باخذ بعض
الاغراض والشخصيات والمتعلقات الشخصيه من
المتعلقات التي التي رصدناها قبل قليل
بالاضافه الى ذلك في نفس اللحظه زياره
الاسعاف خرجت
بالسرير هنا اشاهد ربما ربما لحظه اغماء
او حاله اعياء لبعض العاملين في هذا
الموقع يتم التعامل معها مباشره هي ليست
لاحد تم انتشاله ولكن جهد كبير جدا تقوم
في كل الفرق العامله
ربما بعض الاصابات
لنعم نعم بعض الاصابات التي اتت ربما
لاحظت اعياء او
جراء الارهاق الذي جرى لهم من خلال
التعامل مع هذه
البنايات هنا تقريبا سته بنايات مجاوره
لبعضها البعض في هذا الشارع فقط اللي حولك
فقط ست بنايات مهمه بالكامل في الشارع
الاخر
اذا اللي جنبك مباشره في الشارع ستنايات
بالاضافه لذلك قدرت اعرف كم تم عدد اللي
تم انقاذهم بالمجمل من الست بنايات واذا
في اهالي عم تحكي معهم بعدهم ناطرين يعني
اقارب لهم او اصدقاء في جنبها البنايات هل
عم تقدروا يعني بسبب الاوضاع هناك انه
تتواصلوا معهم بوضوح
نعم نتواصل في بعض الاحيان مع
السكان والاهالي الذين ينتظرون ذويهم في
هذا الموقع تحديدا هم في الحقيقه كان
اعدادهم ضخمه وكبيره جدا في المساء او في
الصباح يوم الامس حتى في النهار وقبل
الامس لكن اعدادهم بدات تتضاءل بشكل كبير
جدا
تحدثت مع جزء منهم كانوا يعني في حاله
ماساويه طاهر لا يستطيعون الحديث يريدون
ايه اخبار تشير الى ذويهم تشير الى حالتهم
تشير حتى وصلت بين الحاله الى الياس الى
انهم يريدون فقط الجثه فبالتالي حاله
ماساويه جدا يعيشها الاهالي هنا من
جراء الانتظار الكبير في هذا الموقع
بالاضافه الى ذلك وهنالك بعض البنايات في
الخلف التي كانت تعمل عليها فرق الانقاذ
تم التعامل او كان هنالك خطا من قبل فريق
الاليات الضخمه تركيا الذي عمل على بعض
بعض الاليات التي بالخطا ضربت بعض القواعد
لبعض المنازل فبالتالي تم الانسحاب الفرق
من مواقع مختلفه في هذه الحي في في خلف
هذه البنايه تحديدا نظرا لخطوره ذلك
الموقع وايلته للسقوط بايه لحظه فبالتالي
الفرق التي العامله فيها في هذه المواقع
ايضا تتعرض
لمخاطر كبيره جدا في
عملها وفي
عمليات الانقاذ المستمره وايضا اللافت بان
فرق الانقاذ السعوديه قدمت ببعض الاجهزه
التي تستشعر
تستشعر الهزات للمباني
المختلفه او المحيطه فبالتالي يتم
استشعارها مباشره ما اذا كان هنالك هزات
يتم التعامل معها مباشره او اخلاء المكان
بشكل مباشر لكي لا يكون هنالك خطوره كبيره
جدا ولعلي
استعرض بعض
الاليه او الادوات التي يتم استخدامها
فريق الشرطه طلب منا ان لا نذهب في ذلك
الموقع فبالتالي سنعود الى موقعنا هذا
التزاما بالتعليمات طاهر
هذه هي الحاله وهذا هو المشهد في هذا
الموقع الذي
يعني ومنع تجاوز نقاط معينه اضافه الى فرد
لحظات صمت احيانا يعني نتركك هنا يعني على
امل ان نعود اليك لاحقا مع اخبار جيده
وبانتظار ايضا ان تتضح صوره اكثر من عند
عمار فيها طايه واضح ان رجال الانقاذ لا
يزالون يعملون بوضوح
على خلف هذه الاليات التي امامنا على
الشاشه لانقاذ السيده المفترض انها ناجيه
على امل ان لا يكون الوقت في غير صالحها
شكرا لكما الان عمار الهندي مفرد العربيه
الى هاتاي جنوب تركيا شكرا لموفد العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي من غازي عنتاب
حملنا شوي حبيبي الله يخليك
[موسيقى]
صاحي يلا بسم الله
بسم الله الذي لا يضر مع اسمه شيء
شوي شوي
[موسيقى]
والعماره صارت تتحرك
صارت رجفه العرض شوي رجعنا فزينا فزعانين
صار الحيطان تمر على الاولاد البنايات عم
تهبط على الارض
على اخواتي بس انا الحمد لله ما صعدني شيء
انا واختي وطلعنا من البدايه ما بعرف كيف
[موسيقى]
الزلزال والمدمر الذي هزه سوريا وتركيا
دفع بدول عده لتنحيه الحسابات والعقوبات
واعطاء الاولويه للاغاثه والمساعدات
الانسانيه فبالنسبه الى سوريا رفعت واشنطن
العقوبات لمده 180 يوما اما تركيا فقد هب
الكثير من الجيران لمساعدتها بعيدا عن اي
خلافات دبلوماسيه الكوارث لم تصطدم
بخرسانات متهاويه لكنها تخطتها لترفع
جدران عزله احاطت بالنظام السوري لسنوات
واعادت خلط اوراق الرئيس التركي السياسيه
زلزال السادس من فبراير حل مدمرا قتل وفرق
وشرد لكنه اسقط حواجز وخلافات سياسيه
هيمنه على علاقات دول لحين لملمت الماساه
فازاح الدول لا ترتبط بعلاقات طيبه مع
تركيا او سوريا ملفاتها موضع الخلاف
وانضمت الى قافله المساعدين
واشنطن استعانت باستثناءات خاصه بالعمليات
الانسانيه لتعلق العقوبات المفروضه على
سوريا وتسمح بادخال المساعدات اليها
وفي وقت ارسلت فرق انقاذ لتركيا اكتفت
بتقديم المساعده لسوريا عبر شركاء محليين
لرفضها التعامل مع الاسد اما في تركيا
فانفتح الطاقات التعاون من مختلف الجهات
فالحدود مع ارمينيا فتحت لاول مره منذ
عقود لادخال المساعدات رغم خلافات تاريخيه
الجار اليوناني تخطط توترات كادت ان تصل
لمواجهه عسكريه بسبب نزاعات على جزر
وتنقيب عن مصادر الطاقه دبلوماسيه الزلزال
شملت زياره لوزير الخارجيه اليوناني برفقه
نظيره التركي الى انطاكيا وارسال مساعدات
انسانيه وفرق اغاثه وعمال انقاذ لتحقق ما
قاله السفير التركي السابق لدى اثنا
بخطابه الوداعي تمنيات بعدم الحاجه لكوارث
او زلازل لتذكر الجيره
السويد تناست موقف تركيا المعرقله لمسع
انضمامها لحلف شمال الاطلسي فطور العلاقات
لم يؤخر مصر كذلك عن ارسال مساعدات طبيه
الى تركيا كما لم تؤثر العمليات العسكريه
التركيه شمال العراق في تضمين انقره
بالجسر الجوي الاغاثي
معنا من على الحدود السوريه التركيه
الصحفي خالد ابو المجد اهلا بك معنا استاذ
خالد حقيقه الوضع الان لما تعرفه من اخبار
عما يجري في الميدان من محاولات انتشال
على الجانبين وكذلك بخصوص ادخال المساعدات
عبر الحدود السوريه التركيه او من معابر
داخل حتى
نعم طاهر طبعا عمليات الانقاذ ربما في
تركيا تبدو اكبر الان والسبب بان زلزال
كان مركزه انطاكيا وكذلك مرعش وعمليات
انقاذ بوتيره ربما اكثر بقليل هي داخل في
الداخل التركية في الداخل السوري فرق
الدفاع المدني منذ يومين اعلنت انتهائها
بمرحله الانقاذ وانتقلت الى مرحله
الانتشار الضحايا والسبب بانه
كانت قد سيطرت فرق الدفاع المدني وكذلك
فرق الانقاذ على كل او اغلب المناطق
وقاموا بانقاذ كل الذين سمعوا لهم اصوات
من تحت المباني الوضع ماساوي جدا انتقلنا
الى مرحله اخرى من الماساه ما بعد الزلزال
مرحله الزلزال وانقاذ الضحايا كانت مرحله
اولى لكن الان دخلنا في مرحله ايضا صعبه
جدا الا وهي
ايواء المشردين الذين نجوا من تحت الانقاض
وكذلك منازلهم
نعم مرحله التعافي كما يسميها الدفاع
المدني تفضل نعم طاهر مرحله تبدو صعبه جدا
على الجهه الاولى لم كنا لم نكن نتوقع
باننا سندخل في مرحله اخرى من هذه الماساه
والماساه تبدو صعبه جدا بروده الطقس لم
تساعد الاهالي على على ايجاد ماوى لهم
هناك بنيت كثير من الخيام سواء كان في
الجنوب تركي او في شمال سوريا لكن برد
الطقس لم تسمح للاهالي العوده الى او عفوا
يعني التاقلم وكثير منهم غامر او خطره
وعاد الى منزله اما ان المساعدات الامميه
فدخلت الى الداخل السوري لكن اول قافله
دخلت هي بعد اليوم السادس الامم المتحده
يعني ليس من الضروري ان نذكر نحن كيف قصرت
الامم المتحده هي بذاتها اعترفت بان بانها
خذلت الشمال السوري ووجب عليها لم لم ت
هذا الخذلان وكذلك يعني
احاطت هذه المشكله التي وقعت في بالنسبه
للشارع السوري دخلت عدد من القافلات الامم
المتحده كقوافل اسعافيه عبر معبر باب
الهوى وكذلك دخلت بعض المساعدات من
كردستان حتى بعض الناس عم تخاطر ترجع على
مباني متصدعه يعني بخاطروا يرجعوا اليها
يعني كي لا يبقوا في الخيام
طبيعي جدا اولا لنشرح كامل المشهد في
الشمال السوري المباني اساسا قبل الزلزال
هي معرضه لزلزال من قبل قوات النظام التي
قصفت هذه المنطقه على مدار عشره اعوام في
الطيران فهي منذ البدايه منازل مصدعه
وكثير منها سقوط او او غير مؤهل للسكن عند
قدوم هذا الزلزال تدمرت المباني التي كانت
مضادعه وكذلك
اثر الزلزال على عدد من المباني الكبيره
هذه المرحله الثانيه اما النقطه الثالثه
فهناك مباني ليست بها اي شيء لكن خوف
الاهالي من هؤلاء الزلزال الاول لم يسمح
لهم بالعوده الى المنازل والتخوف مشروع
فمن شاهد ومن عائشه وانا احدهم هذه اللحظه
قبل اسبوع من الان تماما لن تصفها الا
بيوم القيامه حتما وكل ما تحدثنا عنه لن
يصف هذه الاحوال التي مرت على الشعب
التركي والشعب السوري
معلش بعد قليل معي من الاديمان الان محمود
شكر مفرد العربيه محمود كيف تبدو عندك
الصوره الان اي جديد
نعم الصوره هي ان الورشه التي كانت تعمل
في عدد من الاحياء الداخليه لرفع الاناقات
للوصول الى ناجين هي خفت وتيرتها مع
الساعات هذا الليل وهذه المساله هي محطه
يختلف عن الايام الماضيه حيث كان يستمر
العمل من الليل حتى الفجر على مدى 24 ساعه
في هذه البنايه التي هي وراءنا مباشره
انتهوا منها منذ حوالي ثلاث ساعات بالوصول
الى ام وطفلتها والى والد والى ثلاثه من
اطفاله قالوا لنا الى انه 50 تقريبا هم
ضحايا عدد هذه البنايه المؤلفه من عشره
طوابق في كل طابق يوجد شقتان المشهديه في
المدينه ونحن في الشارع الرئيسي الداخلي
فيها هي ان القوافل لا زالت تستمر في
الدخول اليها اذا اخذنا ايضا كيف نشاهد
الان هذه الشاحنات التي هي تصل تباعا الى
المدينه هذه تحمل المواد
الغائب مواد الاغاثه بالاضافه الى شاحنات
اخرى كانت تنقل الحطب من مدن اخرى والى
جرافات بالتوازي منذ ساعه كان فريق
بريطاني يبحث ايضا داخل احد الاحياء عن
احياء معهم مزودين بكلب مدرب ولكن
بالمقابل ايضا لنا في المقرب الاخر هنالك
مخيبهم والان منذ حوالي عشر دقائق شهدناهم
وهم يعودون في موكبهم بمعنى انهم لم
يتمكنوا من الحصول على ناجين يظهر الى انه
بدات مرحله رفع
تدريجيا في المدينه هذه المدينه التي عصف
بها الزلزال يوجد فيها ما يقارب
1800 بنايه مهدمه وعشرات الالاف من الشقق
المتصدعه يصح بها القول انه في هذه الليله
لا يبيت احد من سكانها في داخل بيتها الجل
الاكبر وهم الان في امكنه ايواء مخصصه
يعني
ما طبيعتها
الاكبر الجل الاكبر هم قامت الحكومه
بنقلهم عبر ثلاثه طرق مواصلات
فتحت مطار
المدينه باتجاه المحافظات الاخرى وسيارت
قوافل للحافلات الى المحافظات الاخرى كما
ان من عنده سياره وله اقارب هو غادر ما
تبقى منهم ومن لم يستطع هو لا يزال في
المخيمات التي هي منتشره ومتوزعه في كل
ارجاء المدينه بالاضافه ايضا الى ان
الحكومه كانت قد وعدت الى انه لكل عائله
منزل على مدى سنه ستدفع له الايجار
المدينه
باكملها خرجت عن الخدمه ولكن عادت اليها
بعض الخدمات الاساسيه في مناطق محدوده
الشارع الذي نراه عاده الكهرباء اليه بعض
الشوارع الداخليه ليس هنالك كهرباء اما في
كل الاحياء هي مقطوعه المياه مقطوعه لا
زالت في اليوم السابع اليوم الغاز ايضا
مقطوع وايضا الاتصالات هي محصوره في بعض
الاحياء دون الاحياء الاخرى لان كل
الاعمده الارسال عصفه بها الزلزال طالب هي
مدينه باكملها من كانت تحت الارض اصبح فوق
الارض ومن كان فوق الارض اصبح تحت الارض
ربما لم تكن تتخيل عندما يعني طلب منك ان
تتحرك الى تركيا ان يكون هذا هو الواقع
على انه يعني ان ترى كل ذلك غير ان تشاهد
وتسمع يعني من وسائل الاعلام بدون شك يعني
محمود اتابع معك في
تغطيتنا من ادي يمان تحديدا
نتابع في رؤيه ومشاهده صور التي تزودنا
بها لوصول المساعدات قوافل المساعدات الى
هذه المنطقه مع يعني
الامل الذي بهت او خفت في الفتره الاخيره
والساعات الاخيره بعد الايام السبعه من
وجود ناجين تحت الانقاض
لاسالك اكثر عن كلام الناس وما يقولونه
لجهه يعني ما يمكن ان يحصل في الايام
المقبله هل هناك مطالبات للفرق الانقاذ
باستمرار عمليات الانتشال والبحث هل هناك
من لا يزال من اهل من اصدقاء فيه اماكن
تهدم البنايات يبحث او انه المشهد باتا
مختلفا تماما في هذا اليوم السابع
نعم نعم طاهر تسمعني نعم اسمعك
انت لم تسمع السؤال نعم
الاهش هنا يبقون لمده طويله يتسمرون لمده
طويله امام الابنيه اباء لا يمكنهم ان
يتركوا ابنائهم تحت الركاب ولو هم يدركون
حقيقه انهم اموات هم ينتظرون
الان ينتظرون ايضا من ياتي
ليساعدهم او لياتي ويقوم بهذا العمل
المستمر ولكن ايضا لابقى معك في بعض
الاحيان وفي بعض الاماكن الاخرى الاحياء
الاخرى حتى الساعه لم تصل اليها فرق
الانقاض ولم يصل اليها
الفرق حتى تعمل على رفع الاوقات للوصول
الى جثث في المقرب الاخر في الحي حيث يسكن
الجل الاكبر من السوريين كان لهم يرفع
الصوت الى اب يقول منذ ثلاثه ايام
التقيناه وغدا سنذهب الى المكان الى انه
طلب من عده فرق ان تاتي الى البنايه لان
تعثر على جثه ابنته هو يعرف انها ميته
ولكن لم تذهب لذلك سنتابع هذه القضيه اما
في المقلب الجزء الثاني من السؤال طاهر
وضع كثير صعب خاصه في الاتصالات يعني نت
ابدا هو ياتي ثم بعد ذلك يذهب لذلك هنالك
تقطعات بيني وبينك على مستوى الصوت لا
مشكله اطلاقا نحاول ان يعني ان نغطي مختلف
الزوايا في عموم المنطقه حيث انت وحيث
بقيه المراسلين
لانه الواقع يختلف بين حاله واخرى وبين
قصه انسانيه واخرى ولابد للمشاهد ان يطلع
عليها جميعا يعني هل يعني من اسباب واضحه
محمود
اقولها لكم فرق الانقاذ تذكرها يعني الوضع
صعب طبعا ولكن لابد من ان نسال انه ما
الذي يعني التركيز كيف يتم على امكنه
مقابل امكنه اخرى كما ذكرت لنا قبل قليل
بانه في اماكن متروكه تماما يعني بمعنى
انه تحدد تستطيع فرق الانقاذ تحديد بانه
هذه اماكن مفقود منها الامل مئه بالمئه او
في اسباب اخرى او ماذا
نعم لربما هذا ان الفرق القاص في بدايه
الامر هي
ذهبت الى المراكز الاساسيه او السنتر في
المدينه وتركت الاحياء التي هي
الاحياء المحيطه خارج المدينه ولكن في هذه
الايام بعد اليوم السابع لربما القول الى
ان فرق الانقاذ ستقوم او قامت بعمليه مسح
لكل الاحياء داخل المدينه دخان
لكل الاحياء داخل المدينه لذلك
في الاسبوع القادم نتحدث عن نهايه الاسبوع
هذا في الزلزال وبدايه اخرى لاسبوع سيكون
هنالك مسح نهائي لكل الاحياء
ويظهر الى انه سيبدا عمليه رفع الانقاذ
وعمليات دخول الشاحنات والرافعات
والحفارات لرفع الانقاذ من كل الاحياء
لربما ان المدينه 70 الى 80 من منها هو
ايل للسقوط او يجب ان يتم رفعه وعمليه رنه
في مكان وتشبيعه في مكان اخر على حسب
اوساط الحكومه للبدء ببناء ايضا مدينه
جديده اكتفي معك بهذا القدر محمود شكر الى
موفد العربيه الى اديمان شكرا جزيلا على
كل هذه التفاصيل يعني نقدر الموقف ايضا مع
هذا الدخان المتصاعد الان من عندك اعود
الى خالد ابو المجد الحدود من الحدود
السوريه التركيه اهلا بك خالد مره جديده
اذا كنا نتحدث عن
الحاجيات عن بعض الارقام ووضع المعابر
يمكن ان تتابع الان تفضل
نعم طبعا وضع المعابر الان هي المعابر
مفتوحه بشكل كامل معبر باب الهوى بشكل
رئيسي الذي تعتمد عليه الامم المتحده
وكذلك معبر باب السلامه ومعبر الراعي كل
هذه المعابر مفتوحه امام كل فرق سواء كان
دوليه او محليه او حتى متطوعين ان يقوموا
بالقدوم الى هذه المنطقه دخلت مساعدات
امنيه وكما ذكرنا ان الامم المتحده اعترفت
بانها خذلت الشعب السوري في الشمال السوري
لكن الان
تقوم هذه الامم المتحده وكذلك منظمات
انسانيه اخرى بارسال مساعدات الان فرق هل
بشكل يعوض عن التاخر عن كل ذلك التاخر مع
فتح هذه المعابر الثلاثه او لا تزال لا
يزال بالامكان للقيام بما هو اكثر
صراحه المساعدات لم تكن على قدر المسؤوليه
منذ بدايه الوقت لكن الان كل ما هو ياتي
للمنطقه هو يحدث فارق بشكل كبير والسبب
ذكرناه سابقا بان انتقلنا من مرحله
الانقاذ الى مرحله ان تؤوي عشرات بالمئات
الناس الان هذه هي المساعدات التي تاتي
كما ذكرنا تحدث فارق من المؤكد هناك فرق
قطريه وكذلك وهناك مساعدات سعوديه بشكل
كبير وهناك مساعدات اتت من اقليم كردستان
العراق وكذلك لا ننسى بان هناك مساعدات من
الامم المتحده الان العمل يتحدثون عن
الاغذيه عن مواد طبيه عن خيام عن اغطيه
الى ما هنالك نعم طبعا هناك مساعدات طبيه
اسعافيه المشافي في المنطقه اعلنت حاجتها
الماسه لكثير من انواع الادويه الاسعافيه
وفي بعض المساعدات هناك خيام وهناك
اسفنجات وطراحات وكل ما يلزم ايواء هؤلاء
النازحين نصبت بعض الخيام وكذلك فتحت بعض
المنازل تخيل بان هناك من كانوا يعانون
داخل المخيمات وماساتهم فيها فصل الشتاء
هم ذاتهم من فتحوا قيامهم يعني هناك قصص
صراحه
حرجه جدا وصعبه في نفس الوقت هي كم هي
قويه من رغم الالم هناك من هم نازحون من
سنوات فتحوا هذه الخيام وتقاسموها مع
الناجين سكن من خرج من قصف قوه نظام ومن
خرج من الزلزال وسكنوا خيمه واحده والجميع
تقاسم الالم الان هناك نصبت عدد من
المخيمات وهناك طبعا وعود بتعويض عدد كبير
من المدنيين وكذلك بناء بعض المناطق
لايوائهم والوضع الان يعني ربما يتحسن
نوعا ما عشرات الاف العائلات التي تسكن
الان العرب نامل خيرا شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المعلومات خالد ابو المجد الصحفيه من
الحدود سوريا تركيا
غير قوه الزلزال الهائله ثم عوامل اخرى
كان لها دور في ارتفاع اعداد الضحايا
فالزلزال وحده لا يقتل الناس فقط انما
ايضا مخالفات البناء
شواهد قبور ضحايا الزلزال باتت تميز
بالارقام بدلا من الاسماء
فالتعرف على هويه الضحايا لم يعد متاحا
لذويهم امام حجم الكارثه
[موسيقى]
قوه زلزال عند سبع درجات لم تسجل في
التاريخ الا 20 مره كان اخرها في نيبال
بقوه سبع درجات فاصل ثمانيه عام 2015
حينها اودى بتسعه الاف شخص
[موسيقى]
هناك عوامل اخرى غير حركه الطبقات
التكتونيه كانت وراء وقوع هذه الاعداد
الضخمه
[موسيقى]
مباغته الزلزال في الرابعه صباحا جعلت
النائمون يجدون انفسهم عانقين عندما
انهارت منازلهم فضلا عن تاخر استجابه اطقم
الاغاثه في هذه الساعه المبكره
عشر ولايات ضربها الزلزال شتت جهود عمليات
الانقاذ من حيث تحديد اولويه المناطق
الاكثر احتياجا
فالساعات الذهبيه هي الاولى في عمليات
الانقاذ لكنها جاءت متاخره بفعل انهيارات
الطرق المؤديه الى المواقع المتاثره ليصل
بعضهم في اليوم الثاني والثالث الى تلك
الوجات
مخالفه متعهد البناء لمعايير مقاومه
الزلزال التي تفردها التشريعات في تركيا
على وقع زلزال عام 1999
سيدي الحديدي العربيه
نعود الى اخطاء ولكن مع النشط المدني بكر
كحلاوي اهلا بك معنا استاذ بكر اخر
المعلومات لديك
تطهر ما زالت فرق الانقاص تعمل على
استخراج الجثث والمصابين ومن يخرج صوتهم
حتى الان لكن انا في صدد التنويه الى
حال السوريين في الجنوب التركي
السوريين يتعرضون الان الى
مرحله نزوح جديده بعد هروبهم ونزوحهم من
قصف قوات النظام الان السوريين امام تحدي
جديد في الخروج خارج المدن المنكوبه
والبدء بحياه جديده مع الاسف مع الاسف
توردنا اخبار مؤكده بان بالامس مثلا
ان الذين وصلوا الى ولايه مرسين وكانوا قد
جلسوا في السكن الحكومي للطالبات بعد تم
اخراجهم منه اخراجهم منه في منتصف الليل
وتركهم في العراء ولايه مرسين اليوم لم
تقوم بتسجيل اي اي متضرر سوري جاء اليها
المقصد ان السوريين الان في وضع سيء ومن
اجل هذا نحن نناشد مفوضيه اللاجئين
بالتدخل واستلام ملف السوريين لان الدوله
التركيه حاليا هي لا تستطيع اللحاق
بمواطنيها فما بالك باللاجئين والمقيمين
على اراضيها
يعني باعتراف وزاره الداخليه وزير
الداخليه ان بعض البلديات تقوم بترك
السوريين بالعراق العنصريون يستغلون
الموقف ويقومون بالتجيش ضد السوريين لاجل
هذا السوريين الان بعيدا عنها طاي بعيدا
عن بعيدا عن الانقاب بعيدا عن استخراجهم
تحت الانقاذ نحن في امام امام تحدي كبير
جدا
باجلاء السوريين ومساعدتهم على بدء حياه
جديده خارج هذه المدن
بالتالي هم يضطرون الى يعني التوجه الى
خيارات اخرى ويضطرون الى النزوح بعد
النزوح الى مناطق اخرى بسبب تماما
تماما مرسين احدى المدن القريبه يعني اقرب
المدن هي واضنه اقرب المدن التي تعتبر
امنه بعد وصولهم الى مرسين وجلوسهم في
مراكز الايواء ومن بعضها السكنات الجامعيه
قام رئيس حزب النصر التركي اريد اصدار
بتجييش الناس في مرسين واقامه مؤتمر صحفي
امام السكن الجامعي وطالب باخراج هؤلاء
السوريون والبلديه استجابت له وقامت
باخراج السوريين وتركهم في العراء هذا
الحال ليس فقط في مرسين هذا الحال موجود
في عده ولايات اخرى لكن هذا ما شاهدته
بامي عيني وما وصلني ايضا
السلطات المعنيه وصلت انها لم تتحرك
اطلاقا في في هذا المجال السلطات
الان يعني كما قال يعني تستطيعون العوده
الى المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الداخليه اعترف
بنفسه ولاما هذه البلديات التي لم تقم
بمساعده السوريين وقال لهم حرفا هل تريدون
ان تتركوهم ان يموتون في البرد فافعلوا
ذلك بمعنى ان السلطات التركيه الان تحت
امام ضغط كبير جدا وتحدي كبير جدا قد لا
تكاد قد لا تكاد تستطيع تدارك الامر حاليا
المصاب كبير جدا عشر مدن تضررت لاضرار
دمرت بالكامل كما كما تحدثنا سابقا الان
انا اوجه نداء لمفوضيه اللاجئين واجه نداء
الى المقتدرين والى رجال الاعمال السوريون
الزمن الان للتحرك هو الان علينا الان
الوقوف بجانب بعضنا البعض السوريون الان
بدون اي دعم تخيل ان السوريه الان بدون اي
دعم علينا الوقوف بجانب بعضنا اناشد كل
سوري في اي مدينه يستطيع ان يفتح منزله
لمتضررين الزلزال ان يقوم بذلك باسرع وقت
ممكن رجال الاعمال الائتلاف
المعارضه كل من يستطيع التدخل في الوضع
السوري وضع السوريين حاليا خارج هاتاي
باتا اسوا من وضع السوريين داخلها استطيع
قول هذا بشكل واضح جدا جدا
مناسبه يعني مهمه جدا يعني التفاصيل اكثر
عن طبيعه المساعدات التي يمكن ان تقدم ممن
هم في الخارج من هناك شكوك لدى البعض
بطبيعه بعض المنظمات وبطبيعه بعض يعني من
يطلبون المساعده او تحويلات ماليه او الى
ما هنالك كيف يمكن ان تطمئن الخارج على
ذلك
ان انوه ان جميع من تدخل لمساعده السوريين
واجلائهم حتى الان من داخل هاتاي الى
خارجها ومساعدتهم هي منظمات مجتمع هي
متطوعون امثالنا هي اناس ليست لها علاقه
لا بالحكومه ولا بالائتلاف ولا غيرها
التدخل كان من المجتمع من المنظمات
المجتمع المدني والفرق التطوعيه الان
الموضوع بات اكبر من قدره منظمات المجتمع
المدني والفرق التطوعيه الدوله التركيه لا
نقول ان الدوله التركيه تقوم بالتقصير
الدوله التركيه كما قلت وزير الداخليه
بنفسه يعترف بهذا لكن الموضوع الان موضوع
يعود الى رئيس البلديه ووالي كل مدينه على
رساله وصلت يجب ان نتوقف هنا بكر كحلاوي
النشط المدني شكرا جزيلا لك نخدم هذه
الساعه ولكن تغطيه مستمره مع ميسون بعد
قليل الى اللقاء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]